[inaudible].
Good.
This is Jocko podcast number one 60 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good evening.
October.
I'm going to head your way
then.
See you today
though.
Sometimes I wonder why should
sometimes you don't seem to care
and that makes me mad brother.
Okay,
and then when I see you,
it doesn't really make me feel any better
should it?
Is that what this is for?
It doesn't seem to be.
It actually just makes me remember the way things used to be
better times.
It makes me wonder why things turned out this way.
What did I do wrong?
Should I have done something different?
What could I have said?
You never let me down ever.
Yeah,
but now you won't even talk to me.
I was looking at some of the things you wrote to me in the past.
I opened up in the email.
Yeah,
in it you wrote,
I feel it again,
washing over me.
The descent into degeneration and disintegration,
the smell of filth,
black water,
mixed blood and gunpowder and shit.
The American soldier covered in filth 11 months into a 16 month deployment.
The insurgence,
grown men hiding behind children,
women wailing over the dead,
explosions and screams and fragments of concrete flying through the air
and frog men entered the scene to take the hand of the American soldier and pull
him from the whirlpool
to set his feet back on the rock and speak words of hope.
Okay.
We are the prophets of doom and destruction.
We enter an area and take back the lost pride of America.
We read in the stripes blue the field and make the stars of our tattered and
humiliated battle.
Enson shine.
Once again,
we hold it high.
Yeah,
we carry a nation on our shoulders and we bring the enemy to its knees.
Yeah.
We do not live in fear of death or wounding or even worse rejection by the
country we love.
Okay.
I feel my mind coming apart and the old sleeping animal coming out.
I tried to keep it inside,
but it cannot help but attend the call to battle.
When you originally wrote that to me,
I thought to myself,
Yup,
he's there again,
where he should be.
I knew it wouldn't last forever,
but where are you now?
Now you seem distant
in my head.
I can see you smile.
I can hear you laugh.
Yeah,
but it's only in my head.
I was surfing the other day.
It was one of those days.
Good day,
solid swell.
No wind.
Tide was low in the sky was clear and bright.
I kept looking out toward the outside
where you used to sit and wait for the big set waves.
I thought I saw you a couple of times,
but it wasn't you.
I heard someone paddling behind me.
Must be you.
I thought,
no,
nothing.
No one's there.
I'm all alone.
Out here.
Everything is the same,
but nothing is the same.
Everything has changed,
but nothing has changed.
Does anything ever change?
Look at the waves.
As they approached the shore,
each wave formed through random combinations of wind and sea and pressure and
each one completely unique.
And when they break,
they're gone forever.
But then another one comes behind it
and another one,
they are all different,
but they're all the same.
And I see some of the past and the future and I see some of the future and the
past and I begin to wonder which is which.
How did I get here?
Where am I going to end up?
Where are you?
I look at some more of your writing.
You are telling a story,
writing a story about a man,
about God,
about life,
about death,
and this is what you wrote.
Yeah,
I am ready to go.
He thought to himself,
but for you,
I wait for the appointed time.
THY will.
He said to himself and closed his eyes and placed his hands on the pages as if
there was some strength there and he prayed
while he prayed.
He also thought of past times
he breathed in deep and exhaled
deliver us from the evil one.
He muttered
and he thought of all the reasons he had no right to say this prayer
at that he steadied himself,
opened his eyes and looked out into the first light of the morning.
He saw a face,
not his own,
looking back at him from the window and disappeared,
but he was not startled.
This kind of thing was normal.
I'm ready for you.
He thought to himself
while he ran that morning.
He did not think about anything.
His mind retreated deep into itself or perhaps it shut down altogether and he
wore no expression.
He only looked out at the sea and watched as the sea birds glided above the
undulating plane of water moving close above its surface,
but managing somehow not to touch it
at home.
He heaved weights around on a small concrete slab.
There's routine effortlessly recited and at the same time painfully undertaken
again without fought or care
every morning the same
marking off time until an appointed end,
his final rendezvous.
That's what you wrote.
Is that what we're doing here?
Marking off time until an appointed end.
My memory plays tricks on me.
How many days do I remember?
How many days do I actually remember
and what good is a day that I can't remember?
Did it happen?
Did it exist?
I want to remember every day,
but I can't.
I let some of them go
and hate that.
Yeah,
I want to remember and we remember the times we had together.
We played songs on the guitar,
but I can't hear them anymore.
They are gone.
I can't
recreate them.
I'm not good enough.
Can we play him again?
One more song.
Here is some more of your writing.
I am God's Messenger.
I am a chieftain of Michael,
the angel.
He has granted my request to help you for it is you who are doing the bidding of
the king.
We have heard your many prayers.
They burned before us day and night.
Yes,
heaven is full of the fragrance of your prayers
and I bring glad tidings from the lord of Lords.
He is preparing his mouth to ride here,
but there is still more to be done on earth before he wields his Skype than
sword upon it.
I bring a message.
The Lord of Lords wants to help you reap the spirits against whom you are
warring.
Indeed,
Satan has asked to have you,
but we will not let that happen.
Of course,
you always have a choice.
I have come a long way though.
I came when we heard your last prayer.
You will not be turned.
When I read that,
it seems obvious
even God was on your side,
but if God was on your side,
how did you up like this then?
How could you do this to me?
Okay,
what about me?
Yeah.
I know I'm being selfish,
but what about me?
You know what?
I'm not going to see you today.
You can wait
after everything I did for you after everything we went through together.
December.
Okay.
I calm down a little bit.
I pride myself in keeping control of my emotions,
but I got to admit you had me breaking down a little bit for awhile.
Do you see that?
You're probably laughing at me,
so I'm going to come up and see you today.
Is that cool?
I mean,
it's supposed to be cool.
If nothing else,
just to say goodbye.
I'll bring you a beer or two.
I don't even drink anymore,
but you know what?
If you crack one open with me,
I'll have one with you
like old times.
What happened to those times
we were brothers
and when we came home we knew
we made it.
We've made it,
man.
Okay.
As crazy it seems.
I was actually never that worried about you.
Maybe you were blessed where maybe you were lucky.
Maybe it was both,
but whatever it was,
it worked.
You even wrote to me during your next appointment,
this is what you wrote.
All I interject is my part,
the firing and yelling,
but the bullets do not hit me.
They never hit me.
They pass through me like a miracle.
Two days ago we drove through a village and knocked all the power lines down and
it was night and the sparks were like incoming RPGs.
Yeah,
I wished they were 10 braced,
but they weren't,
and the Iud is won't come either.
They won't hit me.
Okay.
It's like I'm being
protected.
You capitalized the P in protected.
You believed it was a higher power.
I can't rightly argue with you on that,
but if that's so true,
how does this happen?
Why did this happen?
Where did that protection go?
Did it abandoned you like you abandoned me?
What am I supposed to do now?
You know what?
I'm not going to see you today.
You can wait.
Yeah.
February.
It's a new year.
Let's try this again.
Time heals all wounds.
They say,
so we should be good now,
right?
I should be over it all by now.
I'll come see you and at a minimum say goodbye.
Just just say goodbye.
Just tell you that's it.
No hard feelings.
Don't take it personally.
I've decided I'm gonna go ahead and proceed on down the path without you
alone.
Okay.
Than I'm used to being alone.
No big deal.
I kind of like it,
but even I to admit,
it was nice.
Nice to have someone to talk to.
Nice to have someone to talk to without even talking.
Oh look.
A nod.
A smile.
No one is smiling back anymore.
No one.
Sometimes I look up at the night sky
that can approximate a smile.
I see a smile in the sunset.
I don't know why
I tried a milk,
what I can out of every day,
I should be cursing the sunset.
Okay.
That's sunset means another day has gone.
I shouldn't be cursing it,
but I don't.
I take a few minutes when I can and I watch it.
Good night owl.
Huey.
Good night.
Chesty
good night stoner.
Maybe there's some relief that the day is gone is at it,
that that part of the race is over and there isn't a damn thing I can do about
it.
When my oldest daughter was little,
we would watch the sunset over the ocean when we get the chance.
And she was at that age when she was only just starting to talk,
she could just say a handful of words.
Okay.
When she wanted a drink of milk,
she would say no.
When she wanted to go on the swing,
she would say being,
when I would throw up her up in the air and catch her,
she would laugh and she would giggle and she would say the word again.
And she and I were sitting on the seawall,
it was autumn and the sun was leaning towards the south and we watched and she
watched
the colors in the sky,
red and yellow and orange,
like fire and the water ignited.
Okay.
Then it turned black and the sun disappeared into the ocean and she looked up at
me and she said again,
yeah,
she wanted it back.
Yeah.
But I couldn't do anything for her.
I was powerless.
I still am.
I can't stop the clock and I can't bring back a day.
Not One single day,
not one single minute.
You get what you get.
Okay.
And that sunset,
we'll keep a man's ego in check,
especially when you're complete.
Lack of control,
disappoints the little angel sitting on your knee.
And I can't control this situation either
and that stings.
Okay.
And I don't want to face that.
I don't want to say goodbye.
Okay,
that can wait.
You can wait.
May
springtime
rebirth.
So I'm told
the winter swell fades,
but the water warms up.
The days get longer again.
I like that.
I look at more of your words.
The read,
he found us sleeping spot
happy and excited with anticipation.
He thought of the glory which was to come and he slept trank leak and did not
dream
the blue midnight sky held no trace of trouble.
Almost no clouds,
only a wisp of silver,
gray near the moon.
That seemed to be something beautiful for the below to look at as an omen that
something good might happen
as some kind of sign that heaven awaited it.
The good thing,
the good thing you wrote,
what am I supposed to do with that?
You set me up,
you know with thoughts of the good thing
because there we were,
you know,
we were headed in the right direction toward the good things.
When you listen to me,
things worked out always right.
Do you know it?
When you listened to me and you put your damn heart in check,
things worked out
okay.
What's your problem?
You listened to your heart too much.
You know this.
Let your emotions get ahold of you.
You know it's true.
I told you a thousand times,
10,000 times
and you tried to listen and you did listen sometimes,
but your heart couldn't be completely subdued.
It was too strong,
too strong for its own good
and yeah,
I know,
I know.
That's what makes you you
fine.
But you should have listened to me.
You should have listened
and now I am here and you are there and there is nothing I can do about it.
Okay.
Powerless July,
full fledged summer.
Now
camp fires and guitar on the regular.
Where are you at?
Let me ask you something.
If you weren't going to come around then can you just let me be,
I don't want you in my head right now.
I don't want to get dragged back.
Every time I strum a cord,
I remember
we were traveling up the coast.
You May.
Yeah.
Lazy days.
Surfing by day,
playing on the gift boxes at night.
We were looking for bigger waves.
The kind of waves that get the blood flowing.
We found some,
but what will we really looking for?
Yeah.
You know as well as I,
we were looking for that thing.
Yeah.
That moment,
that moment when nothing else matters.
That moment that is sourced directly from the battlefield.
Hard to find anywhere else.
So we,
we try and get close to it,
Jujitsu,
surfing,
whatever,
but it's hard to replace.
Maybe it can't be replaced.
Maybe it just is what it is.
I think I understood that.
I'm not sure you did.
I was able to rationalize it.
Figure out,
detach from it,
see it from the outside.
Before that trip up the coast,
you had written me.
These words
send us.
We are thirsty for screams and Gore and hell and Dirk and shit.
We will hack our way through scores of bodies,
form them up in a pile and burn them so we can kill by the pyre lights.
Somebody spread the good news that the killers teeth are sharp and their guns
are clean and their souls are dead,
so no one needs anything but victory and sacred deference when is done.
You see that was your heart talking again.
The same heart that wrapped around a girl you met,
the same heart that brought my kids birthday presents the same heart that was
broken by the loss of our friends.
A heart capable of both devotion and destruction.
I told you to let it all go.
I told you,
but I can't control everything.
I'm still powerless.
September.
Yeah,
a year has passed
or was it yesterday?
Time seems like a trick,
but the trick is on me because it's no trick.
It all time does not waver.
It does not relinquish.
It isn't tricky.
It just is
and it is moving on without judgment and without mercy and it will keep moving.
Yeah.
I am coming up to see you today.
I have to,
I have to say goodbye.
I can't do it like this anymore.
Carrying you around in my head.
Bringing back the past so often that it's interfering with the present and the
future.
That's not right.
That wasn't part of the deal.
I arrive.
Yeah,
you're still there.
Where I left you.
I brought you a beer when some wax for your board and a guitar pick.
Even though you played better without one.
I already went and saw Mikey and mark.
I save you for last.
That's the way it is.
You were the last to go
and this is the way it always ends
here.
It always ends like this
and I will end up here too.
Yeah,
but I didn't know you'd end up here so soon.
Here's your beer.
I'll pour it in the grass for you.
I'll put this bar of surf.
Wow.
On top of your gravestone,
their guitar pick next to it.
I read the words,
catch dinner.
That white granite rock,
Seth,
a stone
commander,
the u s navy,
Afghanistan,
Iraq.
September 17th,
1976 September 30th,
silver star with oak leaf cluster,
bronze star medal with valor.
Faithful Warrior,
faithful
warrior.
I always tell everyone to carry on
to mourn,
but not to dwell,
but now I'm dwelling myself
and I know I shouldn't.
You know I should.
I've thought long and hard about it
and I was going to say goodbye.
Yeah,
but I'm not going to say it.
There is no need.
Yeah,
you're still with me.
You're in the ocean and in the sky and the earth beneath my feet.
Okay.
You're still with me
and I'm good with that.
Here's one more thing you wrote.
Yeah.
I fought.
The enemy is good as I could.
I lost myself,
but in doing so,
I found myself.
It is a path
you have to work your own one out.
It is a struggle.
I've listened to the truth.
I am humbled and mystified
by this life we live.
That's what you said.
And I will tell you this,
my brother.
Yeah.
Hi.
I am humbled and mystified by this life too.
And I am going to keep on living it.
I can't stop the sunsets and I can't bring them back,
but I can make them count.
And that
is what I am going to do.
I am going to keep on living
and I am going to make it
count.
So
here we are
and
speaking of living life
and trying to make it count,
we're doing this gig here tonight.
So
we are live.
We are.
Yeah.
[inaudible]
we generally this a rough transition.
Yeah.
Little bit.
So everyone that's here,
our first live podcasts.
Thanks for everyone for thanks to everyone for coming down.
Um,
as I thought about what to talk about tonight,
I went down into a pretty heavy subject
and
you know,
that's part of what this whole thing is.
Um,
all the people that have reached out to me over the last few years ago that were
able to overcome some tough situation
because of the podcast.
And it's the same with me,
the same lessons that we've learned from the podcast,
from books,
from having people on.
It's the same.
We get the benefit of two.
I get the benefit of that too.
And
here we are.
Here we are.
So
thanks for coming.
Echo Charles.
Thanks for pressing record.
Okay.
And stopped by the way,
when you got it.
It's a whole,
it's a little thing.
And
uh,
one of the main things and one of the main reasons I wanted to do a live podcast
is to actually see everyone and give a chance for you to see us and for you to
see what we do and what it looks like.
And this is pretty much what it looks like.
I mean,
we're sitting in a small room and we press record and this is what we do.
And it's great to have everyone here and to see your faces.
And I've talked about this before.
I mean,
when I'm recording,
I,
I'm talking to you.
You know what I'm talking to the people that I've heard from over the past few
years.
I know you're listening.
And even from day one I wanted to,
when people put on their headsets,
I wanted them to think like,
okay,
Yep,
this is,
we're going in and this is it like it's on and I don't want you to waste your
time.
I don't want to want to win.
I don't want to waste your time.
So
that's why we're doing this tonight.
I thank you all for coming.
I also want to take advantage of the fact that you're here to do some live Q
and.
A,
which is very fun for me to do.
I enjoy doing it and we did solicit questions from the ticket sales.
Did I just escalate that?
Yeah,
a little bit.
we did that for ticket sales
answer.
We've got some of those questions here and we'll start off with a couple of
those.
And then we've got,
you can bring the Q and a lights on and then we're going to,
we've got some folks out there,
volunteers with microphones and then once we,
we'll,
we'll open it up and we're gonna we're gonna racked in and answer some
questions.
And I know some of you were waiting to get a picture of weeks to get some stuff
signed before this started and we'll finish this and we'll wrap up that for
everybody here.
So it's awesome that you all are sitting here.
Appreciate you coming down.
And um,
let's do a little Q and.
A.
Yeah,
yeah.
All right.
Yeah,
it's interesting cause usually we just sorta see the cameras,
you know,
they're on the other side of the cameras,
but you just see the no,
it's like,
Oh you actually see the peat.
It's different.
So,
all right,
first question,
observation.
Will you see what I'm saying?
Like now I look in the camera like,
Oh,
you see what I'm saying?
I'm just saying,
you see the people awesome.
Well,
let's not blow it anymore.
Leaving in the first question.
We can't edit out your stuff.
Right.
All right.
Jocko,
what impresses you the most when you're considering to work with someone or hire
them to be part of your team?
This is a question I get asked all the time.
Everybody wants to know who to hire and what do I look for.
And obviously I look for someone that's humble and I looked for someone that's
balanced,
Eh,
and really,
you know,
it's one of those things where as much as you can before you hire someone,
get to know them.
And the advice we give people a national on front all the time when they're
looking to hire someone,
as we say,
look,
if you can hire them temporarily,
bring them on as a contractor for 90 days.
You have to see them in the environment that they're actually going into.
They're going to be working in before you know what they're really gonna be
like.
Because just like going through the screen,
people like crazy to go into seal training and it,
they can't tell who's gonna make it and who's not.
Gonna make it.
They just can't tell and they you,
you work with people in the seal teams and you think you know what they're going
to be like when you go into combat,
but you just can't tell you.
You can have a decent idea,
but you just can't tell.
And so if you get the opportunity or the best way to do it is try and bring
people on board in a manner so you get to know him better.
And then once you know them,
you can either hire them or you can get rid of them easily.
Next question,
make sense
Jocko?
For a new entrepreneur or someone new to a leadership position,
who is meeting with their employees or direct report or direct reports for the
first time,
what are some key things to address during that initial conversation?
As soon as you meet someone that's going to be working for you,
you're immediately make an impression.
So we want to make a good impression.
We also don't want to go,
okay.
It's a,
it's a dichotomy because you're immediately building a relationship with them,
but you can't go overboard and be all buddy buddy with them.
That's why I followed the Hackworth model and I actually took that to the next
level.
Hackworth wouldn't like laugh and joke around with the troops for six weeks.
I upped that to eight weeks cause I'm a little bit more hardcore.
Yeah.
So you,
but,
but one thing that's good out of the gate is put out some brief general
guidelines,
like some,
some of the most broad guidance that you can possibly give,
which is,
hey look,
here's what's important to me.
We're going to do a great job.
We're going to work hard and this is our mission and this is what we're going to
focus on.
And that's it.
You don't need to come out of the gate trying to show everyone that you're the
murderer.
You don't need to do that.
Guess what?
You're the boss.
You actually defacto are the man.
So don't run around and try and prove yourself out of the gate.
Get to know him,
let that relationship builds over time.
And that's what we're going to end up in the best situation.
Makes Sense.
You sort of did that to me.
Even as friends
like here.
Yeah.
Good to meet you.
Here's you.
Eight weeks.
Just like that next question.
Yeah.
Well it's funny too,
cause now when I meet people,
like tonight,
I'm all nice to everyone now.
Yeah,
he changed.
But if I was going to be like
getting in the game with them and somehow make cold blooded,
that eight week probationary Jocko period.
Who are some of the well known leaders today who you believe best exemplify
extreme ownership?
Be it in politics,
military or business.
Uh,
military.
You know,
obviously I like,
I like Madison a lot by matter of fact,
I'd like madness.
Yeah.
Thank you.
I I general Kelly,
same thing.
Yup.
And McMaster,
same thing.
All those guys are awesome.
A chrome macfarlane or general macfarlane who just retired who I worked before
and Remati who is awesome.
So there's a lot of really good military examples.
The business examples.
There's a,
uh,
lolly who turned around Ford.
There's a great book called American icon and it's a great leadership book.
I actually was going to cover it,
but I never did because it's hard to cover books about business compared to
books about combat,
but it's a really good book.
American icon,
great ownership,
great attitude,
and politics.
Six.
Okay.
This was a super hard one,
but then I just thought,
oh,
Dan Crenshaw,
and really
just the way Dan,
since he's taken position,
like he's just doing a great job.
It's very,
very cool to see.
So yeah,
there you go.
What else?
Go to four.
Cool.
Hi Jocko.
An Echo.
I recently read the book marine,
the life of chesty puller and in the book chesty references and the unnecessary
loads of administrative paperwork that was required to be prepared for the
military.
I also recently remember on it on a recent podcast,
you recalling a situation in Ramadi where your platoon leaders were not thrilled
to fill out required paperwork.
I'm a squad sergeant in a prominent American police department and I'm
experiencing the same dilemma of micro managing and oversight is extreme and up
to in,
it's taken a toll on the morale of the officer's citywide.
The tedious paperwork and constant micro managing is preventing good cups from
being proactive.
I feel like the job,
quote unquote,
has changed beyond recognition.
I'd appreciate your advice on how to approach the bullshit paperwork
and increase the morale of my cops.
Thank you for your time.
Okay,
so what would I do in this situation?
First of all,
I am going to be awesome at the paperwork.
I'm going to do it so well that,
because if you blow off the paperwork,
then you go to your boss and say the paperwork socks and it's not any good.
The guy looks at you and says,
Oh,
you know what?
You don't even know how to do the paperwork.
How do you know if it's,
how do you know if it's hard or not?
So what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna do,
I'm gonna Start building a case.
That's what I'm going to do.
So I'm going to do the paperwork.
I'm actually going to log down how many hours I put into the paperwork.
I'm going to follow that paperwork and see where it goes and see if anyone
actually reads it right.
Cause if I can go to my boss and say,
Hey,
I spent 28 hours a week filing this paperwork and no,
not one single person read it.
And then you take the manpower of everyone in the department and then what you
do is you actually build a case.
When you go in to talk to the boss,
you should have a full magazine of ammunition to combat this paperwork that
you're being forced to do.
You have to be able to explain it to them in a rational,
logical manner and you can't,
okay.
You can't make any headway against your,
if you are trying to fight from the low ground,
the low ground is why don't really turn in the paperwork and I don't really do
the paperwork and I think the paperwork is crap.
Then they're looking down on you.
What are you talking about?
How are you?
Dare you say that you don't even do it.
You don't even know what you're doing.
You've got to get on the high ground.
How do you get on the high ground?
You get all that stuff done to the best of your ability.
You logged down the hours it takes.
You get your whole little team doing it and you tell your whole team,
hey look,
I know this is painful right now.
Everyone in this squad,
everyone in this platoon is going to do all this.
We're going to lock down what it takes because I am going to bring a solid case
up the chain of command of where we need to limit this paperwork.
This is a long war situation.
You know how long it took to build up all that paperwork.
It took years.
It took 20 years,
30 years for that to happen.
I used to joke about the marines,
the navy seal teams,
the range,
our range procedures are super loose.
We go out there and we shoot like crazy and do all kinds of really dynamic
things and we'd sometimes go to a Marine Corps range.
It was like everything was super tight and I would tell my guys and say,
look,
that's because that happened over years.
One mistake happens.
How do you stop that mistake from happening again?
Put a rule in place that stops it.
Another mistakes happen,
another mistake happens.
Put another rule in place,
Put a piece,
a piece of paper to stop it from happening again.
And eventually you end up with a range that's barely even usable.
So that's what happened in this department.
There was little things that happened over time and they build and they build
upon themselves and the next thing you know,
you can't even recognize what your actual job was.
So we have to it.
So that took 20 years to happen.
You're not going to undo it overnight and you're definitely not going to undo it
from the low ground.
You have to get the high ground,
you have to be a performer.
If you're not a performer,
you have no say,
do your job,
do it well,
fight a long war.
[inaudible]
I'm all of a sudden thinking like maybe we need one of those little applause
tracks,
you know,
when I answer a question,
when is good man.
Good.
Uh,
next question.
What book has had the biggest impact on you and is a must read?
Yeah,
I'll face Hackworth.
Thanks for coming.
Welcome to the club.
All right,
good on.
Okay,
next question.
Good morning.
Was that like I'm in a rock and roll band.
Just lets the crowd sing the chorus a little bit,
little bit.
If you did not join the military,
what do you think you'd be doing right now?
I think I would have ended up either in the Police Department or a firefighter.
That's what I think I would've done if I couldn't have gotten into the military.
That's probably what I would end up doing.
Y
just because I had the urge to serve
and do something physical and do something where I'm helping protect people.
I think that's why.
Yeah.
So I know there's a lot of cops and firefighters here,
so thanks for what you do.
[inaudible]
what is the relationship between humility and vulnerability?
Okay.
The relationship between humility and vulnerability.
Okay,
interesting.
And there's an interesting dynamic that you get going on when you,
yeah,
when you're humble.
Okay,
so let's think about what happens when you're humble.
When you're humble,
you expose your vulnerabilities.
But what's cool is when you expose your vulnerabilities,
they become less vulnerable.
So that's why being humble as a win,
because if I'm taking over a position and I don't know how to do one of the
jobs,
if I hide it,
it's haunting me,
right?
And it's a weakness because as soon as it gets exposed,
I'm going to look like you know,
week and a loser.
But if I have a vulnerability and I'm humble enough to expose my vulnerability
and say,
Hey,
you know what guys?
I haven't actually done this before in my old unit,
we didn't never did this,
and I don't know how to do it.
Can I get some help here?
There I'm being humble,
I'm exposing my vulnerability,
and all of a sudden it's not a vulnerability anymore because the,
because my team actually knows it and guess what?
Then I get to practice and learn about the thing that was making me vulnerable.
So vulgar,
making yourself vulnerable is fine,
and if you want to kill your vulnerabilities,
you have to,
okay.
Be Humble enough to expose them voluntarily,
voluntarily.
Exposing your vulnerabilities is infinitely better than hiding them and letting
them be uncovered by the
seal teams.
That's what it is.
It's,
it's,
it's animals.
Like everyone else in your platoon,
if you have a vulnerability and you hide it and then they get it,
like they're coming at you
with daggers,
with knives and they're going to,
so if you say,
hey,
this is the situation,
expose those vulnerability.
Be Humble enough to do that.
You'll be in a much better position.
Yeah.
And it seems like the leader,
like if you're the boss and you're trying to make like,
oh yeah,
I know everything.
And then like I said,
they,
they find it,
you look way more stupid.
Like in the beginning it feels like you looks more stupid in the beginning I
would think anyway.
Like,
aw,
I'm the boss,
I suppose to know all this stuff.
Yeah.
I think the key point of that is way more stupid.
You don't want to look like that?
I don't think so in there anyway.
All right.
I'm going to go back to this other one,
three dinner,
guests living or dead and why
three dinner guests living or dead?
Uh,
Mark Lee.
Mike Months.
Brian.
Joe.
Okay.
[inaudible]
how did you get the nickname Jocko?
I answered this on Facebook live.
Not fully though.
I didn't know fully.
Anyways,
before I was born,
my dad wanted me to be a jock.
My Dad's name is John.
My Dad's nickname is John.
No.
My Dad wanted me to be a jock.
My mom calls my Dad Johnno.
My Dad said,
I hope he's a jock.
My mom said a jock.
Oh,
good.
Yeah.
I don't think you said that whole thing.
No,
that's the deal.
And then I actually,
when I said that,
my mom said,
actually my dad was nicknamed John.
Oh,
not by her,
but by his family because he was named after his uncle whose name was John Ogle
fork or something like that.
Yeah,
man,
it goes deep.
There you go.
Right.
Question for Jocko.
Do you teach your wife about being strategic and how open is she?
How open is she that having her husband beat her teacher?
That's a good one.
That's a,
that's a,
that's,
that's a good one for who?
For,
for,
for
ruining my life.
It's,
it's a good one for me.
For sure.
Okay.
First of all,
let's assess this.
How many people,
just people,
we're not even talking spouses.
How many people are just super open to being taught?
Like if I was like,
let me teach you all something
that already starts off on a bad footing because it implies that I know
something you don't know,
I can help you.
You're,
you're,
you're s inferior to me.
You lack the knowledge that I have.
Clearly I must instruct you in a strategic ways,
right?
Lily.
Okay.
And if that's not offensive to someone,
it is offensive to my wife.
Uh,
so do I sit around and,
you know,
trying to teach my wife,
here's the deal.
Here's the deal.
When we're dealing with our kids,
I absolutely do this.
Now that I think about it,
you know,
I'll say to my wife,
hey listen,
oh the boys doing this and you're trying to do this.
Don't do that.
All you're doing is,
you know,
it's Oh he wants,
he wants to get all crazy cool,
do this.
You're trying to combat,
I used to tell you this when,
when the kids were really small,
cause she's super nice and concerned and wants to make things right and wants to
win arguments,
which when you're trying to win a logical argument with a four year old,
doesn't work,
doesn't work.
And I say,
look,
you're arguing logic with a four year old.
So I think there's an appropriate time to do it.
You have to be careful that you're not trying to,
you know,
be the superior human with,
oh Mr Strategy,
you want to teach me something about cats,
so take it easy.
And all that being said,
I do have strategic conversations with my wife about the family team,
right?
Like we're a business like left your house and your family has a business,
you have income,
you have expenditures,
you have longterm strategic goals.
So those kinds of things we talk about and you know,
I'm the one that's sort of is usually saying,
hey,
what about this strategic goal?
What are you doing over here?
What do you wanna do that?
So we have those conversations,
but not so much me saying how but me,
you know,
US figuring out where we're going together.
Life.
Does she ever like teach you how to be strategic in any way?
Like be more sensitive or anything like that,
bro.
You serious?
Okay.
No,
actually my,
the cool thing about my wife is she knows me really well and accepts.
There's uphold deal.
She accepts the shortfalls.
She knows that she got what she got and she rolled the dice.
Hey,
sorry.
next wish.
Can you share how someone that is introverted and has social anxiety can become
a leader?
I mean,
first of all,
if you've got social anxiety,
you need to go through that exposure therapy,
which is what I wrote about in way the warrior kid that I didn't know I was
writing about it.
I didn't know it was an actual psychological methodology until Jordan Peterson
was explaining to me that,
well,
what you do with someone in this situation is you give them small exposure.
I was like,
oh,
that's what happens in a way of the warrior kid.
Yeah,
I'm smarter than I thought.
So you can do the same thing with the social anxiety.
You know,
you start talking in front of small groups,
you grow,
you get out and hang out with people and you,
you continue to do that until you get more comfortable.
So you can,
you can sort of overcome that.
And it's the same thing with being introverted.
Now there,
there are leaders that are more introverted.
But what you have to do is you have to bring people onto your team to compliment
that area where you're a little bit weak.
So if,
if you're a leader,
guess what you have to do?
You have to communicate to other human beings and sometimes you have to
communicate,
communicate to other human beings in large groups.
That's what happens.
That's what a leader does.
Sure.
Sometimes it can be on the phone and sometimes it can be on email.
Sometimes it can be in radio over the radio.
But there's times where you're going to have to communicate to the people that
you're leading.
So if you're super introverted and uncomfortable with that and it's a challenge,
you're going to have to overcome that challenge.
Yes,
you can get better at it through practice,
but some people are not going to ever get a really comfortable,
some people are never going to get really comfortable talking in front of a
group.
And so what you do in that situation is you bring someone in your team that is
really good at it and then when it's time to address the troops,
you,
you know,
you as the leader stand up and say,
here's the two things I'm worried about on this operation.
Here's where we're heading.
And now bill's going to brief you on the details of the plan.
And that's fine because bill's a loud mouth and bill's going to get up there and
communicate really clearly and that's going to be great.
And you still gave enough as the figurehead and as the leader of the
organization that people go,
okay,
Yep,
we heard from Jocko,
you know,
he put out the word,
he didn't say much.
It doesn't even seem like he has to,
we,
we hear where he's coming from.
So you just have to build a team that's going to compliment your weaknesses.
And you know,
generally if you're introverted,
well that means you're good at some other thing that that loud mouth isn't good
at,
right?
The loud mouth,
the roots go in the front door,
kick it down,
and he doesn't have any sort of
tactical sense of how to run an operation smoothly.
So you come up with a good plan and then you brief it to bill,
loud mouth bill,
and then you say,
Bill,
we're going to brief the troops and then you make it happen.
So you have to do a little bit of both.
You have to improve your personal skills would you can do through exposure and
practice.
Don't get up and talk about things that you don't know.
Get up and talk about things that you do know that you're are comfortable with
and you practice and while you're practicing,
while you're getting a better at that,
you also build a team where you compliment your own weaknesses and we all have
leadership weaknesses and you've got to build teams that can complement that.
Yeah,
agree.
I'm glad.
Next question.
How can one guide or lead a leader above you,
especially when you're many links away on the chain of command or many links wet
down the chain of command.
Oh,
so,
okay.
You want a guide,
a leader that's far away from you and the chain of command.
Yeah.
You've got to build a relationship with that person.
That's what you gotta do.
In fact,
leadership is about building trust and building relationships with people and
trust his leadership and leadership is trust and relationships or trust and
relationships or leadership.
These are like the,
the Trifecta of becoming a good leader.
You build trust with people,
you build relationships.
And in a situation like this,
if I have no,
if you and I don't know each other very well and I come up to you and say,
Hey,
I think you should do this.
I mean,
what's your reaction?
Right?
If you just approach someone that you don't have a relationship with and then
you start telling them how to run things that that's offensive,
that's offensive to like most human beings.
I have to,
I have to get to know you.
I have to see what kind of approach is going to work for you,
cause you might be the kind of person,
if I know you a little bit where you're like,
you know what?
I'm really working on my leadership.
What do you think I could do better?
That's great.
Then we opened the door and we can move forward.
You might be the kind of person that I have to flank.
You might be the kind of person that you won't listen to me,
but I say,
oh,
you should check out this book that I read or whatever.
There's ways to do it,
but to look at a target
and know how you're going to attack the target without knowing anything about
it,
without having an any,
any intelligence on it,
that's not going to be effective.
So we have to actually gather some intelligence about the target we have to and
the way we do that is by building a relationship with,
by getting to know that person.
Once you know the person,
then you can start to infuse and shift and mold and sculpt and influence the way
that they lead.
You have to build that relationship.
To kick things off,
next question,
I'm not in the military nor am I a firefighter or law enforcement.
I'm an air traffic controller here in the New York area and I found myself in
several leadership positions without within our union,
since I read extreme ownership,
I've tried to implement this and the ideals that come with it.
Overall I believe it's been a success and of course still a work in progress.
Specifically the communication aspect of ensuring our people,
no,
why are we doing,
why are we are doing something and how it affects them as it's has been the
biggest influence and game changer in my opinion.
Unions typically come hand in hand with what about me,
attitudes and we definitely have that within our ranks.
This is something I've been trying to tackle with both new air controllers,
new controllers and older ones.
And I think I'm making headway slowly but surely.
Thanks.
See you in life.
My question is this,
have you ever had direct experience dealing with unions and this particular
mindset?
Is there any advice that you can have you have specific to labor unions that
could make this more effective or efficient?
Yeah,
we,
well we work with businesses all the time and we certainly work with businesses
that are involved with or that that either are unionized or partially unionized.
And yeah,
this is something that can be very,
very common.
And the reason that can become very,
very common is because the union
is,
is an organization,
right?
And the company,
the,
the corporate,
the headquarters is a separate organization.
And so what happens is as we let these two elements grow,
they,
they tend to grow apart and they tend to start looking out for themselves.
And that becomes problematic.
It becomes problematic in any organization where you've got the union on one
side.
And what the union starts looking out for is what's good for them and what
corporate is looking out for,
what headquarters,
looking out for us,
what's good for them.
And what happens is we stopped talking to each other and we,
and what we failed to realize is that both those entities have a common goal.
They have a common goal.
And the,
the more we work together to achieve that common goal,
the better off both entities will be.
So what this boils down to,
and the where I would focus step number one in this,
this is a long fight.
This is a long war is trying to make sure that the union side,
cause you're,
you're talking about from your position in the Union,
the union side understands how working with corporate headquarters,
how working with them will benefit the individuals in the union in the long run.
So,
and that a great book to read about this is that book I mentioned earlier with
Malali,
uh,
American icon and,
and what he,
you know,
what he told the unions was,
hey listen,
I get it.
You want your hourly wage to be $76 an hour.
You want to take care of the union?
That's awesome.
Let me tell you what's going to happen in 18 months if we keep paying that we're
not going to have a company anymore.
Here's the numbers,
here's how it's going to work.
And they lowered down their hourly rate to $55 an hour.
That's a huge cut.
And you can imagine the union thinking that's we lost,
we lost.
But Malali did a great job of saying,
no,
we lose.
If we don't come together,
we lose if we don't try and achieve our actual mission,
the mission that we're all focused on,
which is making great cars and being a profitable company.
So same thing here.
Make sure that the areas that overlap the common mission,
make sure that everyone understands how achieving the common mission benefits
both parties.
Makes Sense.
Next question.
I've been a police officer.
If you guys wrote some long questions for Echo Charles Reed,
he's been studying them for four hours.
I've been a police officer
for about four years.
I consider myself to be proactive and try to get after it every day.
Much like many of my brother and sister law enforcement officers recently I
switched to a bigger agency with a,
with a bit of a different mission.
I still try to be as proactive and as thorough as I can in everything that I do,
but I've noticed that many of the frontline supervisors in this agency want
officers to be reactive rather than proactive.
The supervisor in particular has told me to stop working so hard and get salty
suggesting that I lower my morale.
The question is how do I build a relationship with these supervisors while still
being proactive and working hard?
So this is what I did when I got to seal team one,
I was this guy right here.
I was fired up.
I was,
hey,
oh,
we're doing an obstacle course today.
Cool.
I'm going to wear my ruck sack with a 40 pound sandbag in it.
And all the guys that were older were,
you know,
looking at me like,
dude,
pump brakes
and you know,
of course,
what did I think those cards are hardcore core.
Those guys are weak.
That's what I was thinking.
And then,
you know,
I thought to myself,
how can I,
how can I have influence over them?
How can I have influence over the platoon that I'm in?
Can I have influence over the platoon that I'm in?
If everyone that's in my platoon doesn't like me?
No.
Can you,
if everyone in my platoon doesn't like me because I'm super hardcore,
then are they going to steer it all in my direction?
No.
The answer's no.
In fact,
they're going to isolate me.
I'm going to have no influence over my platoon and that's a,
that's a horrible thing.
So what did I do?
Did I just go,
okay,
cool.
It looks like donuts is the deal.
No,
I didn't do that at all.
But I conformed,
I conform and people think,
oh,
that's weak.
You shouldn't conform.
Look,
you are not the priority.
You as an individual are not the priority in a seal platoon,
you're not.
The priority is the platoon.
The priority is the mission and if we're going to execute a mission,
we need to be very tight as a team.
So if I put my personality above the unity of the team,
I'm hurting our capability of accomplishing the mission,
especially if I realize that guys need to train a little bit harder and instead
of actually doing something that's going to move them in that direction,
they reject me and now I'm outside the,
the Brotherhood,
the circle,
and now I haven't moved them into the right direction at all.
So now there's one guy that's in really good shape,
me and everyone else is going in the other direction and I have no influence
over them that that's just terrible.
The mission is the most important thing.
In order to most effectively execute the mission,
we have to have the best possible team in order to have the best possible team.
We have to have trust and relationships inside the team.
If I
violate that,
I'm taking away from the team.
I'm taking away from our mission capability.
Now,
of course,
if there's someone that's gold closely out of shape or out of standards,
yeah,
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna try and tighten that person up.
But again,
if someone's completely out of standards and all I do is attack them,
what's their reaction?
It's to,
to step away from you to reject me.
But if I,
if I say,
hey man,
you know,
I know you've got a lot of experience and you know,
I'm,
I'm 19 and I just got a bud,
so I'm in pretty good shape,
but like,
can,
can you teach me some of the tactics that,
you know,
and all of a sudden I'm building a relationship with them
and then I say,
Hey,
do you want to go for a little,
a little John with me after work?
And you know,
that guy's done eight deployments and he's tired and he's old,
but he wants to be back in shape because we all want to be in shape.
And he goes,
okay,
a short one
and we're moving in the right direction.
So that's what you need to do.
You have to,
you have to back off a little bit.
You have to find balance and you have to focus on the team and it's better to
have the whole team.
It's better to have 20 people that move a little bit in the right direction.
Then have one person by themselves that's going in the right direction and
everyone else is going in the wrong direction.
So that's what you need to do.
Take the sand bag out of your rucksack a little bit.
And you know,
I ran with jungle boots on,
I did all this stuff and it didn't take me very long to realize I was not doing
the right thing,
not making my team stronger.
I was isolating myself and stopped it.
So this guy,
he should like what?
Start acting just a little bit salty
or you know,
lower his morale appearance a little bit to kind of fit in so to speak.
Yeah.
Do
you want to be part of the team?
If you're not part of the team,
you don't have any influence.
If you don't have any influence,
you can't move the team in the right direction.
If you can't move the team in the right direction,
the team is less mission capable.
That's what you're there for is to make the team more mission capable.
Every moment that you don't do that,
you're,
you're doing something wrong.
So yes,
you don't have to show up.
I mean,
just imagine I was a new guy at seal team one people we show up to run the,
of course the o courses,
obstacle courses are really hard obstacle course and I show up with a rucksack
on with a 40 pound sand bagging it as a new guy.
Yeah.
You know,
of course cop people like God's fired up,
but people were like,
okay,
oh you're,
you're 19 years old and you just got out of buds.
Whatever makes sense,
we don't like you.
So
it's kind of like steering like a big Van,
right?
You can't just start making big turns with a big otherwise.
That thing's gonna tip over a little bit.
See what I'm saying?
No,
you gotta like you can't,
you gotta you gotta go slow.
Is what I'm saying.
Okay.
You guys understand.
Anyway,
next question.
Sure.
Apparently,
apparently the bad thing was it.
Yeah,
it was correct.
That's what some of you that didn't understand it until we understood it,
correct?
Yes,
exactly.
Big outstanding.
Anyway,
my wife and I have four young boys ages between ages three and seven.
We're both running successful,
busy careers.
My question is how do you forge a meaningful connected relationship that
instills discipline and leadership with your kids while balancing today's
demanding 24 seven corporate environment?
Here's a couple things.
Make time.
You have to make time.
You have to make time where you're not looking at your phone,
you're not looking at your emails.
You have to set a good example and I think the most important thing here for
kids age three to seven,
you have to make sure that they understand that what you're doing,
what you're doing and why you're doing it.
They have to understand,
look,
you know,
this house we live in,
we have to pay money for this house that we live in.
You know,
the food that we eat,
we have to pay money for that.
And in order for us to have a secure future where we can still have a house and
we can still have food,
we need to make sure that we have money for the future.
That's why mom and dad works so hard.
It doesn't mean that we wouldn't love to sit around and play with you guys all
day.
We would love to do that in every chance we get.
We're going to do it.
But we have to be able to pay for the things we have and we have to be able to
pay for our future.
And that's why we're working so hard right now so we can have more freedom and
more time with you in the future.
So they have to understand why you're doing what you're doing.
And I'll add this.
So do you,
so do you.
You have to assess why you are working so much that you're taking time away from
your family if you're working so much and taking time away from your family so
that you can get the Mercedes s class instead of the Lexus.
Ask Yourself,
is that why you're doing it and what has more value?
The s class
or the dance recital,
keep yourself in check.
Yeah,
it makes sense to Annie.
You kinda gotta tell the truth to yourself cause ina hall,
like you could answer the email later or at another time,
not dinnertime or whatever.
You know,
he kind of got to be truthful.
That's what I've found anyway.
Helps.
That's why you don't return my emails on time.
Next question.
Was there a time during your service in the teams that stood out above the rest
and would you mind sharing a brief story not before heard on your podcasts?
Well,
obviously the time and the teams was being in tasking at bruiser of been in the
battle of Ramadi.
That's pretty straight forward.
Something that I haven't,
I don't think I've talked about on the podcast,
but it,
it definitely is something that I remember very clearly.
And that is when,
when seal team five came in to take over for us.
And so this was in October of 2006 and seal team five a task unit from seal team
five came in to take over for us and we're doing the turnover with them,
meaning we're explaining to them the battle space and it takes a couple days for
all of them to arrive.
They arrive in bits and pieces and so we're doing the turnover.
But once they were all there,
I did a turnover brief with them,
the whole group.
And as a matter of fact,
Marcus Luttrell was in this group and this was after he had gone through what
he'd gone through enough.
You know,
I just saw Marcus the other day and we were talking about this,
I couldn't believe he was in Ramadi after what he went through.
And this was not long after there.
He was in Ramadi as a platoon leading petty officer and
it was his group of guys.
And I remember one thing I just,
I just remember was looking at them and I was telling them,
yeah,
you are going to take casualties.
Okay.
And
that it's sort of like that thing you see in the movies or I've talked about it,
read it in books about Vietnam where you had guys that were coming in country
and they got new camouflage uniforms on and they're all clean cut and there's
the guys that are getting ready to go home and those guys at that time seals
deploying into a situation you seals deployment situations.
They're kind of unknown.
At least up until this point,
it was like,
okay,
well we're going,
we're going to do missions.
We don't know how bad it's going to be.
It might be bad,
it might not be.
That sort of was the standard.
Those guys that were coming into Ramadi that relieved us,
Ramadi,
they knew and the senior enlisted guys are one of my very good friends.
Those guys knew 100% they went to Mike [inaudible] funeral and then got on a
plane and came over.
They knew 100% and so for me,
I won't forget looking at this group of guys that were about to start a six
month deployment and telling them you are going to take casualties.
And that was just a blunt,
honest truth and
okay,
they did take casualties.
They didn't lose anyone.
They had no one killed,
but they took some very,
very severe casualties and did a great job.
Great Group of guys.
But that was a harsh reality to walk into for sure.
All right,
we'll do one more of these questions before the life question and then we'll go
live
people.
What was your first combat mission and what was your role?
So
2003 I deployed to Baghdad as a seal platoon commander and the senior enlisted
guy of my task unit was already in Baghdad waiting for us.
And this guy is an incredible guy.
Just uh,
as a matter of fact,
his wife tells him and me that were soul mates.
She's jealous.
But anyways,
this guy,
just an incredible guy,
but he had been on the ground for a while and he'd done the push up into Baghdad
with the marines and then he'd come home and then he was back over.
And so he was waiting for us and he was,
it was my platoon.
We show up and I remember we hit the ground.
I don't even know how long we'd been there,
but it wasn't long.
It was,
it might've been like the night we got there and there was mortar teams that
were more during our base and they had been for a few days.
And so this guy,
a couple of mortars went,
I think anyways,
whatever happened,
he comes in like,
you're taking your guys out right now.
You got to take your guys out and go and see if you can find where these things
launched from.
And I was,
I was sort of not ready for that.
You know,
we'd been there for four hours,
but you're taking your guys out and um,
uh,
you know what I said Roger that and you know,
I talked to him later,
like later that night.
And he goes,
yeah,
I was just trying to get you outside the wire and get some.
And I was like,
how about you give me a heads up next time?
So that was it.
I was just running that little vehicle thing and we went out and look for bad
guys.
We didn't find any and came home,
but that was the first kind of exposure outside the wire in Baghdad.
Not a very exciting story.
Sorry.
There we go.
All right.
Um,
so we got some folks running around with microphones and does anyone have a,
does anyone have any questions?
Okay,
let's see a couple of hands anyways,
I'm going to take this thing off so I can sort of move around and see you and
our Mike People.
I'll point
to you and we'll find somebody.
All right,
let's go.
You right there.
Black sweatshirt.
I just,
I was just trying to get him to call and me,
but he wouldn't wait until he took your order.
So you got a good team here.
So you were talking about childbearing before,
so not me personally,
but no,
you had to,
you were cornered.
Um,
any thoughts about having a child rearing book come out?
Like a team childbearing book you've been how to raise kids?
Well,
yeah.
Childbearing.
Yeah.
Um,
I mean maybe not.
Maybe this is a bad thing.
Yeah,
no,
no.
I'll tell you what.
I wrote a couple books.
One is called way of the warrior kid and one one's called Mark Mark's mission.
I read them.
Okay.
Yeah.
I mean the,
the amount of people that have come back to me and said like as a dad,
as a mom,
yeah.
Thank you for writing this book because every time I read it,
I learned.
Now that means that I'm basically saying,
hey,
you need to learn.
You need to pull parse the lessons Outta here.
So perhaps I could be making more straightforward and also,
hey,
as I'm the perfect parent by any stretch,
right.
But one thing that's good about putting ideas on paper is I would start to
clarify things myself and you start looking at,
I would start looking at mistakes that I made and say,
okay,
here's a clear mistake.
I didn't really recognize it before,
but now that I'm detached,
I'm looking back at it.
So yeah,
not a bad idea.
Yep.
Finances,
everything.
Just how to discuss with your kids.
Like all of these things are really important topics and I think the extreme
ownership perspective could be a great addition.
Awesome.
Thank you.
I'll buy it.
Quick question over here.
You,
um,
he's leaving it.
I like to come prepared.
Uh,
good evening Jocko.
Good evening.
What lesson do you wish you would have learned earlier in life that you now
know?
It is discipline equals freedom.
I mean,
that is the thing that,
that when I connected that together in my head,
that,
that the fact that that applies to absolutely everything.
That's the biggest lesson that I wish I would have learned earlier in life.
And if I would have figured that out,
then I would've been doing a lot better and I would've done a lot better.
I would have been a lot better of a person.
The thing that I try to tell kids,
I try and tell him that for sure.
But the other thing that I think kids miss his kids,
and this is something that I completely missed as a kid,
the actions that you take now affect your future.
That sounds so obvious.
But when you're 14 you just think no,
nothing.
I,
you know,
my life is only another 20 minutes.
So what I'm doing right now,
it doesn't really matter.
So when I talk to kids,
I try and explain to them that discipline equals freedom.
And then I tried to explain to them that what you're doing right now really will
have an impact to where you are in the future.
And I don't know if you listened to that podcast that I do,
the warrior kid podcast that I did number 19 about my friend Jeff and
I talked about it on the adult podcasts as well.
But you know,
it's a classic story.
I had a best friend when I was little and we separated friendship,
not,
we were still friends,
but we,
we drifted apart.
He started getting into partying and getting into drugs and all that and I
didn't.
And his trajectory in life just went down and I joined the navy,
which was great and it put me on a good path almost involuntarily,
but he ended up,
he ended up killing himself and you know,
it was drugs and it was alcohol and it was just bad.
But while I was going through buds,
he killed himself.
And what I tried to explain to the kids on the warrior could podcasts is like
the decisions that the little decisions that you make,
they matter and they add up and you have to connect those dots.
Otherwise you don't know where you're going to end up and it might be bad.
Cool.
Got your hand up quick bro.
Good job.
I do,
I do Jocko.
Um,
so first I'm going to say thank you for being here and continuing to inspire us
all.
I really appreciate it.
Um,
so a little backstory.
I'm currently a detective and a Police Department in New Jersey and uh,
sitting number one on the sergeant's list looking to get promoted about march or
April.
So my question is I'm going to be the youngest sergeant in the department and
not with a lot of experience.
Now I've never had an issue in the department,
um,
doing pretty well.
And as soon as that list came out and I was number one,
the tension just rows and when to look at this kid less than five years in the
job,
you know,
in his twenties and they already want to see me fail before I even got to the
position.
So I'm trying to mentally prepare myself in that role when I already know that
it's coming against me.
So what's your best advice for someone that is going to be,
you know,
in this position of,
see I was looking at every position as a leadership position,
but now structurally I'm going to be their supervisor.
So what's your best advice to,
to me going into that situation?
Yeah.
And this is
same exact situation that military officers get put into military officers in
the field teams and the Marine Corps and the army and the navy.
You're a kid that comes out of you have zero experience and you get put in
charge of a department on a ship or you get put in charge of a platoon and all
of a sudden you're a guy with zero experience and you got to platoon chief
that's been in for 16 years.
That's,
that's the way it works,
and so I've had to have this conversation over and over again and what we're
going to do is number one,
we're not going to act like we know everything.
Even if you do know more,
even if you have things more figured out than these guys,
if you go in there and act like it,
guess what they're going to do?
They're going to reject you.
Who is this young whipper snapper?
Young buck thinks he knows everything.
He doesn't know about this.
He doesn't know about that.
They'll sabotage you to make you look bad,
but if you go in there and you're humble,
I'm not talking about being a pushover,
I'm not talking about being weak,
but I'm going to lean towards being humble.
I'm going to lean towards listening to what they have to say.
I'm going to lean towards saying,
hey,
you don't have never handled a case like this before.
Do you have any perspective you can you help me out with this?
Instead of,
Hey,
this case is mine.
Let me show you how it's going to be.
That right there,
you're taking a relationship in a negative direction.
We want wanna.
We want,
we want to build a team and we want them to,
we want to get their respect.
How do you,
how do we get the respect we get?
We actually get respect.
As crazy as it sounds,
we get respect by,
by being humble.
So if,
if,
if echo,
if echo's working for me,
I show up,
he's more experienced than me and I show up and I say,
all right,
here's what we're doing.
Here's how we're doing this mission.
Here's how it's going to be my way and I think he knows what's up.
Now he knows he,
I'm the boss.
What's he actually thinking?
Who's this idiot?
That's how the job for three days and he thinks that he's going to tell me what
to do and he's going to,
he's going to resist it.
He's going to sabotage,
he's going to,
and we're going to have a bad relationship.
But if I come in and say,
hey,
echo,
really great to meet you and you know,
I'm just checking in here.
I was looking at your,
I was like checking out your record.
You've been here for a long time,
man.
You really nailed some big cases.
That's awesome.
I'm looking forward to working with you.
I'm looking forward to learning a lot from you
and boom,
what's his attitude towards me now?
Hey,
this kid is pretty humble.
Again,
I'm not coming in and saying I don't know anything.
Can you please,
you know,
show me the way.
Oh master,
no,
I'm not talking about that.
But just a nice,
respectful,
humble way of treating people study,
show up earlier than they do know the nomenclature that you're supposed to know.
Ask Good questions,
listen to the feedback.
And I've talked about this on the podcast.
If he comes up with a plan and I think I have a better plan,
but he's got a plan that's,
that's pretty solid.
Who's planning?
I got to pick,
I'm going to pick his plan.
I'm not going to force my plan down his throat.
It makes our relationship go backwards.
It makes him think that he needs to compete with me.
I don't want him to coffee.
Hey,
echo,
this is your plane.
He'd come up with it.
You,
you make it happen.
Echo always jokes in music.
I know you do this stuff to me
and he's like,
and it still works
okay.
And I do.
You know,
I do.
It's like,
hey,
if he can come up with a plan,
I would rather we execute his plan because then he cares more about it.
It's his.
So stay humble.
Listen,
work hard.
I appreciate that.
Thanks for your service brother.
[inaudible] front row shattered up quick.
Right here.
You got that thing up quick a game.
All right.
First of all,
let y'all go.
Thank you for being out here in New York.
It's great to finally see your live.
Um,
I just want to be respective.
You already elaborated some on communicating as a family.
He said you're gonna put some more content out regarding that stuff.
Hold on a second,
Bro.
My hearing's not great.
Slow down.
Hit it with [inaudible].
Make it quick and simple.
A top three rules on raising kids from ages three to nine.
Really getting that sort of attitude instilled while they're still young.
So not about the family,
like dynamic,
not about managing,
just the kids' attitudes.
Yeah,
it's with kids.
Well,
you got to remember,
and this is the hardest thing for parents to deal with,
is your kid is not going to be who you want them to be.
They're just not,
they're humans and they have there.
If that was the truth,
all of my kids would be the same type of kid and they would all,
you know,
you could just,
here's what they all do.
They're not there.
They're not.
Your kids are going to be different and your kid's going to be different from
you.
They might be a little bit better than you at some things.
They might be worse than you would other things.
So what you have to do is first of all,
get that idea out of your head.
That being said,
you can definitely provide guidance and you can definitely put them in,
guide them in the right direction.
But what you don't want to do is make every decision for them.
What you don't want to do is only let them do what you tell them to do.
They've got to learn to make decisions,
otherwise they can't go into the world and fend for themselves.
They've got to suffer consequences of their bad decisions,
otherwise they can't fend for themselves in the world.
So you have to,
I've said this before,
you have to,
you have to like let them brush up against the guard rails of failure.
You have to let them tie the one shoe.
You have to let them spill the milk and the more you
make or allow them to do for themselves,
the better human beings they're going to be.
The more that you do for them and force on them and impose on them,
the less they're going to know for themselves.
And the more they're going to rebel against the values that you're putting forth
them.
Again,
it's a dichotomy and I'm not saying,
Hey,
let your kids do whatever you have,
whatever they want.
When they go outside that box,
just give him a nice big box.
When they go outside of that,
you got to bring them back in and you've got to explain to them why you're
bringing them back in.
They got to understand that there's,
the reason they're not allowed to play in this area is because there's bad
people there or there's danger there is not just because I said so.
So you develop these relationships with your kid,
you guide them,
but you don't direct them and you let them be as much of a leader as they can be
and that's the best thing you can do for them.
Thank you.
Can I add one more thing to do that which actually Jocko opened my eyes to this
and it like,
like your kids are always watching you like always what?
So if you're yelling at mom or yelling at people on the phone or,
I don't know,
doing stuff,
you're doing stuff that you don't want them to do,
you can say,
Hey,
don't do this.
They'll be like,
cool.
But once they kind of get the opportunity there,
like I guess this is kind of how,
because dad does it,
especially with the yelling thing and losing lake.
Dot.
How do you deal with stress and stuff?
That's probably,
they'll jump right on that.
That's what I,
that's what I really noticed when actually when he opened my eyes to it,
I was like,
oh,
okay.
You know when you know sometimes you get kids or your kids,
how many kids you have.
Oh,
okay.
All right.
Well you're planning ahead.
Okay.
All right.
There you go.
We'll keep this in mind then.
Cause a lot of the times you're like,
oh,
your three year old.
Or He'd be like,
Dang,
where did they,
how did they pick that up?
I didn't teach them that.
And the thing is,
you probably will have taught them that just by doing it on your own,
you know?
Yeah.
The,
so they're always watching you.
So that make,
that helped me.
I think a lot type two kids
tighten your game up a little bit around the kids.
Let's see.
Really tall hand to back there you.
Thank you.
So a very specific example then.
Um,
my son,
he's three.
I would love for him to get into Brazilian Jujitsu just like me,
which I also got into.
Thanks to you two gentlemen.
Thank you very much.
Uh,
so how do I encourage him without pushing him,
without,
you know,
just getting him into it.
Really.
Oh
you have to make it fun.
You have to make it fun and it is much better for it to be fun once a week then
for them to hate it three times a week.
The kid that hates it three times a week and you think I'm doing them a favor?
I'm doing her a favor cause I got her in there.
Whether she likes it or not.
She's three years old,
bro.
Okay.
The best possible thing you can do is not make them train Jujitsu right now.
It's make them enjoy Jujitsu.
Right now.
I did not do this well with my kids.
I didn't,
it's horrible when my,
when my specialty,
my daughters,
my daughter,
they were very young.
It was Jujitsu,
Jujitsu,
Jujitsu.
We were doing,
they were doing Jujitsu six days a week.
They were like six.
And that was,
that was,
that was part of it.
Let me tell you what I did.
That's worse.
What's worse is I was like,
okay,
you're also going to compete cause competing makes you better.
And it gets worse because then it was,
oh,
when I take you to compete,
since I'm the coach,
I'm going to put you in a higher weight class.
I'm going to put you against,
uh,
older kids.
And you know what?
If you lose,
look,
if you lose,
it doesn't matter because you're going to be tougher.
So,
so just go out there and do your best.
If you lose,
don't worry about it.
It's gonna make you tougher.
So my daughters go to compete in Jujitsu Tournament,
Jujitsu Tournament,
Jujitsu tournament.
What happens to them?
They get beat.
I get beat by someone that's older.
They get beat by someone that's heavier.
Is that fun?
No,
that sucks.
What do I think?
What is the idiot think?
Oh,
you're getting tougher.
And so by the time they were 10,
it was like,
I don't want to do any of this crap anymore.
And
it got to a point where I was like,
okay,
look,
this is ridiculous.
Um,
I'm,
I realized the mistake that I made and I just had to back off and,
and luckily my son made it through that time period where he,
he kept training all the time and became very good at Jujitsu and wrestling.
But with the girls,
I,
I didn't do it right.
So find a good school where the Jujitsu is fun.
Don't force it down their throat.
Let me tell you one more really quick story.
My,
my son had a friend who was like,
you know,
his running mate and when he was six years old,
I said,
yeah,
we'll bring your stuff that you did to let him try it.
He tried it at six years old.
He didn't like you tried it one time.
I don't like it.
Got Choked in the crime.
He tried it at age seven.
Hey,
we'll try it again.
Didn't like it,
hated it,
tried it at a j,
didn't like it.
Hated it.
Age Nine his dad trained,
his dad had started training his,
he kind of got to look at like,
oh,
that's pretty cool.
By the time he was nine and he tried it,
he liked it and he liked it because he liked it and he was then old enough to
make the decision and want to train and started training hard and he got good
really quick.
It wasn't like,
oh he missed those four years of training.
They didn't make a big difference is my point.
They don't make a big difference.
So the most important thing you can do as a parent is make it fun for your kids.
Make working out fun.
Make Jujitsu Fun,
make school fun.
Make these things enjoyable.
Make let them win.
You don't put them in positions where they're going to win.
And I'm not saying every time,
because you do have to learn how to lose.
Let them learn to lose when they occasionally let them learn to lose when they
get older,
but
make it fun for him.
That's the key.
Uh,
I'm going to eventually get balcony up there,
but um,
I guess Jew in the back
go
Jacko my questions on the other end of the spectrum for a police officer,
I'm a battalion chief and the Fire Department,
28 years on the department,
how do I relate to the 19 year old?
Can you relay a story that you worked with a 19 year old new seal
and you're trying to get what to happen?
One developed that relationship with them.
You talked about the relationship above me as a leader.
How do I develop that relationship for the newer people below me?
The best way,
okay.
When we start talking about relationships,
and I,
I mentioned this earlier,
what our relationship is is the relationship is trust and that's what a team is.
A team is a bunch of people,
the relationship that all trust each other.
How do I develop trust with someone that's below me in the chain of command?
What I did.
This is what I did to make this happen.
As a platoon commander,
as a task unit commander,
as I was in charge of training,
is those young guys that are coming in.
I gave them responsibility,
I put them in leadership positions.
I remember the first time I took over a platoon with a platoon commander got
fired and we had a training operations that night and I said,
I said a between chief.
I said,
hey,
who's like a,
uh,
a squared away June,
really junior guy.
And he gave me a name and I said,
okay,
he's going to run this mission tonight.
And the platoon was like,
Whoa,
wait,
what are you talking about?
This kid's going to run the mission.
Yup.
And all of a sudden,
what's the kid thinking,
wow,
this guy trusts me to do this.
I'm going to do a good job for him.
And since he trusts me,
I'm starting to trust him.
And the more you do that,
the more you push down that responsibility and you let people lead and you put
trust into them,
the more they're going to trust you.
As long as when something does go wrong,
you don't chop their head off.
When something does go wrong,
you say,
hey look,
let's,
let's take a look at it.
Let's see.
We can learn from it.
And you know what?
Probably my fault cause I didn't give you very good guidance.
So let's learn from it and we'll try it again.
You know what?
You're gonna run the same mission tomorrow night.
I know you can do this.
That's how you build that trust up and that's how you build a team.
Hand came up quick right there.
It's amazing that you can tell him what I'm pointing out.
Jocko Echo.
Thank you for everything that you've given us.
Acknowledging that we all have secrets.
Jocko,
what would you need to see happen that would change your mind about a run at
public office?
What?
Let me finish.
What would be that trigger event to make you say,
okay,
public office.
Stand by to get some.
Okay.
[inaudible]
I'll finish by saying white.
Frankly,
you have a nation of troopers,
both foreign and domestic that believe and know that you're qualified to lead
and ready to lend their support.
MMM.
What would it take?
There is a line somewhere.
There is a line somewhere where,
where I would feel like,
okay,
the,
you know,
the country needs me.
Um,
it's,
it's a pretty distinct line.
It's,
it's,
that world is so,
yeah.
I don't want to use the word corrupt.
Okay.
But,
but,
but because that's not what I'm talking about.
Not talking about like that kind of corruption and there's corruption for sure.
But you know,
you compare the corruption that we have to the rest of the world and it's very
nice.
But there's a different word that I can't quite capture.
There's,
there's dishonesty.
There's stored,
I don't mind the chaos.
Um,
some selfishness.
here's what it is.
I think in order,
I like,
I like when things go wrong.
I know that sounds crazy,
but one of my biggest problems is that I get when things are going good,
I get really bored pretty quickly and I just like,
oh yeah,
that's cool.
Oh,
we,
hey,
the business is doing this,
like my business.
Like,
Hey,
we're doing this.
And I'm like,
all right,
awesome.
We're going right there.
Okay,
cool.
Well what,
what can I look at next?
Like I get,
I get kind of bored when things are going well and when things are going bad,
I love it.
I really like when things are going bad and so in the government
things don't get that bad.
And for me to put my time and effort towards something,
all that,
you know,
really focus,
I would get bored very quickly because you know how to be like,
Hey,
you know what?
We're not doing too bad.
And so until there's something
okay
bad that I feel like,
okay,
it's time.
That's kind of what would,
would,
would make me roll in that direction.
Um,
it seems like a miserable life to me.
It seems like a miserable life.
It seems like a life where you're constantly putting up a facade and I don't
have the desire to do that.
You know,
I never got interested in going into the CIA or anything like that because I
never wanted to live that kind of life.
And it does,
I'm not saying it's bad.
I mean the guys worked with them and they're awesome,
but it's just not me.
And I don't like to live that way.
And it seems like there's a lot of that except the fact that if we got into a
position as a nation where things were really bad and we needed some,
we needed to take action,
then I feel like I would step into it.
But man,
I hope we don't get there.
Let me put you that way.
I hope we don't get there and I don't think we will,
but I appreciate the South Porch and I'm sorry,
a red jacket.
Oh,
first off,
thank you for everything you do.
And then,
um,
my question is who we are role models growing up and like what qualities did
they have?
Uh,
well my,
my first legitimate role models that I looked at and said,
okay,
that's a person that I can emulate.
That was when I got to the seal teams.
Up to that point,
I was looking,
I was a confused kid that was looking at this,
you know,
this person,
that person,
but I didn't really,
even though even I wasn't confused enough to be like,
oh,
I'm going to be like that person and follow what they're doing,
I would look at people I got that seems pretty cool.
That seems pretty cool.
And so it wasn't till I got into the seal teams and there were some people that
you instantly,
when I checked into seal team one,
I'm like,
that guy's awesome.
I've got w that that person right there is awesome.
I'm going to do my best to emulate that person.
And there was probably five or seven people at seal team one when I got there
that I stole as much as I could in terms of how to behave and,
and that was it.
You know a guy named master chief faculty who was super just ultra professional
and everything,
and I was like,
he's so professional.
No one can say anything to him because he's a professional.
Like I'm going to,
I'm going to be like that.
There was a couple other,
there was other guys that I unfortunately mashing faculty died so I'm using his
name but other guys that I just looked at and said,
wow,
that guy's awesome.
So I didn't really have like those kinds of role models until I got to the
no.
Uh,
okay.
Balkin is there anyone on the balcony microphones style
right there
up in the cheap seats.
Okay.
Jacko Echo.
Thank you for your podcast.
Jocko.
Think we service Nico,
thank you for the work that you uh,
you work with Jocko and doing the podcasts also thank you to the men and women
in the service present future and past.
Um,
I come from a corporate environment working,
doing it support.
Now.
My recent role was where I was responsible for supporting 40 to 80 people,
pretty much solo.
And with that I had a manager remote,
you know,
I had a good working relationship with them.
He's former military,
so he would tell me,
do certain things within the environment,
which I would do,
but then his manager would come down and visit and sometimes give me
contradicting situations or orders.
So what do you do when you have your boss telling you one thing?
His boss,
your bosses,
direct response report telling you to do something contradictory.
Yup.
Pretty straight forward.
If,
if my boss,
his boss comes to me and tells me to do something,
I'm like,
Hey,
I just want to make sure that you know that this is what I've been told to do.
And then they say,
yeah,
I don't care what that guy says.
And you go,
okay Roger that.
And then he leaves you go,
Hey,
direct Voss,
here's what's going on.
Boss came down and told me to do this.
I'm here,
I work for you.
You're my boss and I want to tell you what's going on.
Um,
do you want me to proceed or do you want me to stop?
I want to keep you informed.
Here's why.
Okay,
I want to,
I want to do the right thing and this is what's going on.
So just take the information from the boss or the boss's boss.
Got It.
Have you told you know my boss that,
nope,
don't care.
Okay.
You don't care.
Fine.
Hey boss,
your boss is telling me to do this.
I want to let you know what's going on.
It's obviously a tenuous situation because then this guy up above the higher
diamond chain of command and all this,
you didn't do what I told you to do.
Hey,
look,
I'm,
I'm just trying to make sure everyone's informed and,
and that's the way,
that's the way things run.
Smooth dust.
If everyone's informed,
I'm here to support.
Can you guys talk to each other so I know what I'm supposed to be doing down
here?
You,
you got to kind of be the person that that connects the dots here to the best of
your ability.
No problem.
All right.
Let's say you're in an organization and you really want to see it succeed,
but it's being led by someone who is a,
not only steering it in the wrong direction,
they're doing it deliberately and you're not really sure if you can negotiate
with them.
What would your course,
my course of action,
if there's someone above me in the chain of command that's staring us in the
wrong direction,
I'm going to do my best to influence and persuade them.
If I can't do that,
I'm going to do the best to mitigate the risk down the chain of command and the
strategic risk.
I'm going to do my best to mitigate it,
and while I'm doing that,
I'm going to try and inform the other people around that person of the situation
that's going on.
I'm going to,
I'm going to build relationships with the C.
Oh,
with the CFO,
with the,
the CEO you're talking about.
Or if it's the battalion you,
whoever it is,
I'm going to build some relationships with other people so we can get that
person under control.
The other thing we have to remember is sometimes at the bottom,
we don't understand what the strategy is,
and so my first thing is like,
hey boss,
can you explain to me why we're doing this?
Because I,
it doesn't seem right to me for the following reasons.
I want to be able to support what you're saying.
Can you tell me why we're doing it this way?
So sometimes they say,
oh yeah,
it's because of this.
I should have explained that.
Sometimes they say,
wait a second,
what do you mean my strategy's not working down on the front lines?
They don't know.
No one's telling them.
So you have to communicate with them to make sure that,
that they understand that to make sure that you understand what direction you're
supposed to be heading and to make sure that they understand why it's
problematic on the front lines.
If all of that fails and they're just looking,
the telling you to be quiet and they're moving forward in something that's gonna
really be detrimental to the organization.
We got to start trying to figure out how to flank that person and,
and building it,
building a alliances with people that can try and get us going in the right way.
Thank you.
Sorry.
And of course there's,
you know,
there's situations where,
especially in the business environment,
like if you're in a ship and the ship is sinking and you sounded the alarm and
you've tried to,
you've tried to plug the holes and you've told everyone and they're still just
staying on board,
the sinking ship without making any corrections.
There are times we've gotta go,
you know what?
This ship is sinking and I'm not going to stay on it.
That can happen.
We can't,
you can't save every sinking ship.
You can't,
and you've got to know when it's time to go.
Okay,
I'm going to take the lessons learned.
I'm going to go somewhere else.
Thank you.
Yes.
Okay.
First I want to thank you because I am a stage four cancer survivor
[inaudible]
in my darkest hours that a lot of people can't comprehend.
You were there with me,
your voice,
your everything.
Still to this day,
I mean,
discipline equals freedom is a common phrase in my family over the most
monumental to the most ridiculous things like letting the dog out at the same
time,
you know.
Um,
so I want to thank you for that.
With that being said,
I have at one point plans my own funeral.
Didn't think I was going to be here for my kids,
you know,
the worst part of anybody's dreams,
nightmares and then to be at the place where I am right now and not knowing,
obviously I'm young and you know what the future holds.
Nobody's naive how you've been in those similar positions,
just not health wise but you know,
facing death and everything else.
How do you switch from that mindset of like you said when things are going
really bad,
I'm freaking awesome.
Like I kick ass.
Like I really do.
And then when things are kind of calm I'm like,
what do I do now?
Like wow,
am I going to,
you know,
even when you were just saying like your last line,
sometimes they think like you just speak to me.
It's so creepy that
I,
my last chemo was Friday.
I shouldn't be well today,
but I am because I knew I had to be here,
you know?
So
[inaudible]
and then when you said that,
you know,
at the end of your podcast that,
I'm gonna live life,
I'm going to live my days.
How did you get from that transition from,
you know,
possibly,
I don't know if I'm going to come out of this battle.
I don't know if I'm going to come home to,
okay,
I'm here,
life speaking.
Great,
let's party.
And then in between,
like did you have any,
um,
like how did you do,
how did you get from the darkest places to the brightest places and then bring
everything?
My problem is,
is I want to bring,
I,
I've learned my lesson,
like I've learned what I had to have learned now and now to bring it forward
with me,
but not to let it define me,
if that makes sense.
Okay.
And I actually gave this answer to Sam Harris because Sam Harris said to me,
you know,
Jocko,
you've,
you,
you talk about combat as your fondest memories and you know,
the,
the best thing that happened in your life.
It's the high point your life,
which is all true.
And he said,
but then you talk about war being awful.
So which one is it?
And I said to him,
I said,
have you ever known anyone that has had cancer terminal cancer and made it
through?
Have you ever known anyone that that's happened too?
And he's like,
yes.
And I said,
when you talked to them many times they say,
I'm glad that this happened to me,
number one,
because it proved I could take it.
Number two,
it's better me than one of my kids and number three,
now that I know how dark he can get,
I truly appreciate the light in the world.
That's what combat is and was for me.
That's what it was.
It was dark and horrible and I wouldn't wish it on anyone just like you wouldn't
wish cancer on anyone.
But
if I can give them a little knowledge.
Okay.
A little bit of a glimpse in to what it is.
Just like when you stand up here,
people,
crap when you said that people are clapping because they get to see a little bit
of it and they go home tonight and they think,
oh,
what about that girl?
What about that girl
she's fighting,
she's living
and I'm going to live too.
Maybe that's why it had to have cancer.
That's how I look at things.
Now.
I don't pretend to have the cognitive capacity to comprehend the mysteries of
the world,
but maybe you're right
and maybe you're here to let us know
that it can get dark,
but it will get light again.
Absolutely.
And thank you.
Awesome.
[inaudible]
yes.
Hey Jocko.
Thanks for being here.
Um,
I've been in the army for three years now and for the past year I've been
thinking about putting in a packet for special forces selection.
Um,
so I guess I just wanted to ask you to talk a little bit about,
uh,
when you joined the seal teams and what did you do to physically and mentally
prepare yourself?
And,
and generally why did you,
why did you decide to join?
Okay,
man,
I wanted to do that since I was a little kid.
When I heard that,
I heard that the seals,
one of the toughest training,
and that's not necessarily true thing.
All the training is hard.
There's this special forces,
the mar soc units,
the Raiders,
the Air Force,
PJ's and CCC is it?
It's,
everyone's got their awesome special operations units and the training is all
hard and all of them.
When I heard that the seals is the toughest training,
I said,
okay,
that's what I want to do.
What do you do to get ready for,
you know what you gotta do to get ready for it?
You,
you know,
army,
guess what?
You're going to be humping a rock.
You're going to be doing forced marches.
You gotta be able to run.
You've got to build a Nav.
You've got to be able to do pushups and pull ups and dips and rope climbs and
off scores.
What you gotta do,
you gotta train hard.
You got to train as hard as you possibly can,
and then you have to tell yourself that you're not going to quit no matter what
happens,
no matter what happens,
you're not going to quit.
Okay?
No matter what happens,
because they going to play a little psychological games on you,
like,
like let's say they go,
oh,
he's in good shape.
He's,
you know,
we can't really touch him physically.
He's in really good shape.
So now you know what they're gonna do.
They're gonna say,
Oh,
you know,
you failed this academic tests.
You're not smart.
You're not really smart enough.
I mean,
you seem like a good guy,
but you're not really smart enough.
You're the creator.
You're the kind of person that will get someone killed.
[inaudible] gonna make a mistake.
They're going to start attacking you psychologically.
Or if you're psychologically strong,
but you're physically weak,
they're going to be like,
hey,
you're the kind of person that won't be able to carry me out combat.
We don't want you.
They're just saying that
don't quit.
That's it.
Don't quit.
Go get some.
All right.
Think one more.
Yeah,
we're looking at,
I want to have some time to hang out.
Sign books.
We gotta be out of here by 11 so
we're getting close.
Go ahead man.
Front row.
Okay.
Jacko thing for a thank you for speaking tonight.
Just a quick question.
I work in a corporation here in New York and one of the toughest things with
being an analyst here,
he's just the fact of like when do you actually escalate or you know,
which,
which kind of feels like defeat but also at the same time you want to make sure
you loop in somebody else to know what's going on,
so just wanted to ask you about that.
Thank you.
For me,
I look at a problem.
If I think I think contain the problem,
then I'm going to try and contain the problem.
I recognize and I weighed the risk of if this is wrong,
what's going to happen?
Can I manage that?
Can I control it?
Can I absorb the impact of that?
If I can absorb the impact of it,
then I know it's like,
okay,
this I need to bring this up.
I need to send this up,
the chain of crap.
If it's something that I know I can absorb the impact of and I can explain
myself and it will be sent and it won't have been a strategic loss or a major
error,
then I'm going to try and hang onto it.
And in the beginning I'm going to be,
I'm going to err towards sending it up the chain of command.
As I start to trust myself and I get better at my job,
I'm going to hang on to more.
But again,
I'm always going to weigh,
is this something that I can contain or I can absorb if it goes wrong?
And if it's something that I can't,
hey,
I'm going to run it by somebody.
So I think it's,
you just got to weigh out and once you weigh that out,
make a decision and live with it.
All right,
got one more
here.
Microphone.
Anyone.
Was there a mic right there?
Um,
as somebody who's,
uh,
recently,
is recently proposed to somebody who would like to spend the rest of my life
with as somebody who's married and has a,
from my knowledge,
uh,
gone away for extensive periods of time from their partner.
Oh,
what is your tips to building a mortar proof marriage that's going to last a
long time?
Yup.
The first thing I'll say is,
you know,
you want to develop the,
you want your,
you want to make sure and encourage your wife to be emo.
I emotionally independent,
emotionally independent because there's going to be times when you're not around
and if they're dependent on you emotionally,
you're not there.
They're gonna,
they're gonna be hurt and they're not gonna be able to handle it.
So you want to help them build that resiliency where when you're not around,
they know how to handle things independently,
like the broken water heater and the flat tire that they can do that.
And you,
you go through those things,
you,
you build that confidence with that.
And then also the emotional independence where what they have is trust in you
that you're gone,
but you're coming back and you're going to be there for them.
Always.
That's number one.
Number two is straight up extreme ownership.
That's what it is.
When something is going wrong in your marriage,
it's your fault.
It's your fault.
The minute you turned your wife and you say you shouldn't have done this,
you're wrong,
and you're,
you're taking that relationship in the wrong direction when you say,
Hey,
look,
I'm trying to figure out how I made you do what you did.
I don't want to let that happen.
So taking ownership when things go wrong,
that's what you gotta do.
That's what you gotta do.
Thank you.
Awesome.
[inaudible]
with that.
Um,
once again,
I can't thank you all enough for coming tonight and I know that you're just not
here tonight.
I know that if you're here tonight,
you're here all the time.
You're with us,
you're supporting us,
you're supporting everything that we're doing.
You're supporting the,
you're representing,
representing,
representing with the store,
with the Jacqueline store,
with the,
with the origin.
You're,
you guys are in the game,
you're getting the books and,
and most important you're,
you're listening and you're with us.
And
the podcast a,
it's a lot of work.
There's a lot of work,
a lot of work goes into it.
But I get more out of it than anyone.
I get more out of doing this than anyone.
And the thing that drives me to keep doing this is not just what I get out of
it,
but also that you all are there and
that you all are listening and that you all are sitting there with us and that
you guys are hearing the same thing that I'm hearing and you're learning the
same things that I'm learning
and I know that we're together.
And I know that
that sounds kind of weird.
That sounds kind of crazy.
But
we are where together we're hanging out,
we're moving forward and
together
we're stronger.
And even though we aren't strong enough to bring back days
and even though we aren't strong enough
to bring back the sunset,
at least,
yeah,
we can sit here together
and we can be humbled and mystified by this life.
And together
we can go out
and we can live it.
I think that's all we've got for tonight.
So thanks for coming down.
And until next time,
this is echo and Jocko out.
[inaudible].